[Music]
the layer heil pancho
sponsored by step finance
your go to d5 portfolio manager on
solana
luna if you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
punch show today is going to be a lot of
fun because we are talking about
entrepreneurship and building in crypto
all of my favorite things but before we
jump into it i do want to let you know
that this is sponsored by blockfi as
usual so you can actually get amazing
interest rates right now i think
actually they are the most competitive
with around nine percent on your stable
coins um i use them i really like them
so if you are interested i have left a
link for you in the comments and in the
description so just um check that out i
think you get around 250 when you sign
up and this is powered by icon plus
capital the bc firm so definitely check
them out all right as i said we are
talking entrepreneurship we are talking
crypto and a little bit of web3 so
joining me today is the ceo of package
portal it is jg hey welcome to the show
how you doing
doing very well thank you thank you for
having me
yeah i'm really excited to chat with you
i haven't been covering a lot of web
three so i'm really happy to have you on
um because i know you're building in
web3 um i don't fully understand
everything so i'm excited to learn and
go into it so
you're essentially tokenizing e-commerce
what does that mean explain that to me
yeah so i guess high-level overview um
we started out tokenizing just delivery
signatures i don't know if you're
familiar with a signature if you get a
package delivered to your house you have
to sign for it if it's expensive uh
there's a fee attached to that and it
averages five to six dollars and i own a
delivery company here in phoenix um i've
owned it for about nine years it's still
operational my brother-in-law runs it
for me right now so i can focus on
package portal um but out of that i
figured out i lost a lot of money and so
did my my staff i've got about 40
drivers and we generated 600 000 in 2019
in signature fees and got none of it the
broker kept it all the middleman kept it
all
and uh this was about a year after i had
learned of crypto uh
one of my drivers actually told me uh
about a token that will remain unnamed
uh that he flipped for a whole lot of
money and i was all ears i knew about
the profit potential of bitcoin and
other cryptos but i didn't really
understand smart contracts
so
once i dug down the rabbit hole of of
the power of automating middleman i
figured out we can you know let's
automate this process we can put a
scanner in the hand of the consumer
so that they can close that supply chain
loop and and provide a digital signature
that's you know it was timely with covet
um
no contaminants you know with the flu
whatever it may be you can you can avoid
touching somebody else's device right so
that was kind of the uh
the foundational core service but from
that we were able to um
just expand a whole lot of feature sets
like the feedback data
consumer data is very valuable we know
that big tech minds this off of us right
they
they listen they monitor they watch
um they aggregate all of your data and
then they package it up and sell it to
advertisers so what we want to do is
flip that and say you as a consumer your
data is valuable and we want to reward
you immediately in the moment for that
data and you know we can wrap it up in
the form of a token and you can do
whatever you want with that earn satoshi
swap out just add value to
the consumer immediately and then
the merchants who want to access that
data can come on and and you know gain
membership to the platform effectively
buying the tokens
from the uh
the consumers are earning them
so in on like a really basic level
you're trying to revolutionize
the delivery service industry is that
right
absolutely yeah uh i think that delivery
as a whole it's a transport service
right the the economy is built off of
consumers and merchants somebody wants
to sell something somebody wants to buy
it they agree on the price and the
transaction is conducted but e-commerce
changes that it introduces a whole new
dynamic of transportation um and that's
where i come from is logistics and so
we have consumed all power
logistics company is just a third-party
middleman right they're a service
provider but
what happens now is the merchant gives
them their money
for the fee gives them their product and
then just crosses their fingers and hope
everything goes well and then wait two
weeks before they
fulfill invoices just to wait for
complaints and damage reports but in
that
the carrier has consumed all power
they house the data and they don't need
to the data should be between the
consumer and the merchant and this this
company can just transport just get it
from a to b
and that's what we hope to do
and you mentioned ernie satoshi's which
was really cool which is one of the
reasons why i wanted to have this
conversation because i love anything
like that so
how how does a customer how does
somebody like me on satoshi's
so
it's possible right now currently i mean
we just launched v2
which is a rebuild version of our
initial launch um right before
thanksgiving so
you can go and download the app right
now and in the play store the app store
and then immediately if you get packages
that you as you have deliveries come
into your house you can input those
tracking numbers monitor it you'll get
notifications by this location and its
status and then when it arrives you can
give a confirmation and then thumbs up
thumbs down kind of like uber uber you
rate it and then you can give customized
feedback too you know lipstick melted
box was damaged the driver was
dirty you know the box was
not there um all sorts of customized
data points that the merchant can
specify if it's a you know food prep
company that's that's sending meals out
they might want to know was the ice
melted or oh wow so wait
a minute
so you can answer hershey's by
essentially reviewing how the delivery
service went
exactly yeah because again you as the
consumer that's very very valuable data
right but you can be rewarded for that
not just you know do it i get i get
emails all the time after a post
purchase experience and they want my
survey i'm not going to provide that
because it's 45 seconds to load your web
page and then click through all this
stuff with no benefit to me as a
consumer you can refine your business
processes and figure out ways to make
more money off of me and everybody else
but i get nothing so we want to flip
that and say the the consumer should
have the power they should have more
power during the delivery experience and
they should have a voice in that and
they should earn um
incentives for providing any sort of
insight
yeah i mean everybody right now in the
industry is trying to build something
with web3 which essentially brings the
power back to the people it rewards them
for their data and it flips it as you
say but like how long until you see this
going mainstream because it all sounds
really great you know even when we talk
about like decentralized social media
platforms and everything that's going on
right now we all really want to have
that kind of decentralized experience
where big tech isn't monetizing us um
but how long you know until this whole
idea is going to go mainstream
well i think we hit an inflection point
sometime in the last few months we've
been building since 2019 so it's trendy
now to say web 3 which is just a really
clever rebrand of crypto um you know uh
it works out really good so we're web we
have web3 solutions but i think that i
think it's here institutions are are
onboarding they want they want in
they're buying nfts um they're going
heavy and long on bitcoin which is good
you know any dip that you see don't
expect it to last
um
it's it's here well what we all we've
been in crypto for a number of years and
and we all fantasized about
institutional buy-in and mainstream
adoption and that sort of thing and
that's really what drove me to start
this company uh in 2018 i got in right
at the top uh the previous top and so i
was putting money in and just watching a
dwindle and rather than just you know
sit on my thumbs and watch the portfolio
melt away i figured it's still very
early what can we do what can we build
i'm not a coder i'm not a software
engineer um but i'm an entrepreneur i
know how to find people who can do
things build things connect the dots
that i can't and together we can
accomplish some really cool stuff
i absolutely love that um you know a lot
of people get really salty and upset
during a bear market um but you went in
at the top and you said i'm gonna build
which is amazing um but you're entirely
bootstrapped right
yeah absolutely yeah so again i own a
delivery company so i had a lot of free
time i could i could focus on the biz
dev um but my engineers they all had day
jobs
my co-founder he's uh he's been a
software programmer for over a decade
has led two teams through acquisitions
in previous companies really experienced
team leader
and he's got two guys that were working
with him in his previous company and for
two years they were nights and weekends
and we launched the product after a year
and a half of testing and so we had a
beta out there for about a year
nights and weekends and it was tough uh
we had explosive growth during that time
and it was hard to manage uh but you
know effectively
nobody was taking the salary it was just
operational costs we would we would
front that and do what we needed to do
and then
at one point
we were able to uh use some of the
treasury tokens and and capitalize a
little bit there was a price run up um
because we do have an altcoin i don't
want to talk about it i want to respect
the show and talk about you know the
entrepreneurship but we were able to
conservatively capitalized you know we
we uh
we we took a little bit out for
operational uh expenses and and now
we're good we have capital we have
runway the guys all went full time back
in june and and with six months of
full-time build time
they were able to
launch a completely rebuilt product
front and back and we have merchant
services so a merchant can go on to uh
our website or our app and view and
aggregate all of this data thumbs up
thumbs down we can isolate in the
chicago area here's everybody who said
they had a bad experience and here's why
um here's all the a heat map of all of
the scans from a particular ship or
flipkart in india um you know we've got
a lot of users globally india indonesia
netherlands
are you in the uk yet
oh yeah
gdpr
yeah oh very good
that's amazing
yeah of course uk regulation is a bit of
a nightmare at the moment when it comes
to this but i think that's so i think
that's so exciting and i think that you
know it's people struggle very much to
try and find their place in the industry
um in the crypto space right they're
like you know what am i am i a trader am
i an investor am i trying to build
something how do i build something so my
question is you know how did you um
kind of just like take the plunge into
building something in crypto right
because like this is so on the forefront
of innovation um you know totally
leading the way i mean everything that's
going on with tech right now so how did
you make that decision
i think effectively i was just trying to
solve my own problem because again i
lost a lot of money in in my delivery
company 600k in a year
now that's nothing to sneeze at because
the middleman was taking them taking the
signature fee is that right
yeah the service is to collect the
signature and that's just it's just they
call it a uh so quick history lesson or
i guess synopsis is is within the
industry there's proof of delivery
anytime you have a package come to your
door
the courier can scan that and he's just
capturing the gps location and the time
stamp and that's it so effectively it's
just some random fourth or fifth party
who's contracted and says i put that
tracking label at that place at that
time and that's where the buck stops
that's not good enough and so a
signature can provide proof or
confirmation that somebody at that
location actually signed now signature
can be forged right drivers with covid
uh you can look it up online fedex all
of the majors everybody put out press
releases and said we will no longer
collect signatures and drivers were
doing authorized forgery effectively
they'll show you at the door and i'll
just put an x here by your name um and
that's kind of standard now oh wait so
because obviously i know that i remember
i remember during covered they wouldn't
do signatures because they didn't want
to like have that contact so they would
just like ring the doorbell leave the
package so are you saying that these
drivers would forge signatures
well i don't want to i don't want to you
know okay
on anybody in particular but yes that
that happens and this in a lot of cases
it's authorized because the the courier
company has said just put an x you know
but that's not good enough because a
driver can put an x and not drop the
package off that is completely
susceptible to you know manipulation and
fraud and on top of that somebody is
paying a fee for a service to be
completed that is not being completed so
if there's a five dollar like six
dollars and 20 cents is dhl for a
signature it's 555 for ups and um
the the usps here in america they're the
cheapest um you know two dollars and 35
cents if you do it online but that's
still
it's a fee tacked on to show that you
did what i already paid you to do
it's a confirmation you know i just want
my receipt you know and so we change
proof of delivery and we offer proof of
receipt
which is putting that scanner that final
uh
the final input the final data point
from the consumer who opened the supply
chain loop in the first place right you
have the shopping cart moment and you uh
the consumer opens up that loop
and then it goes through order processes
and then it finally arrives at this
destination and somebody else who has no
interest in either the brand or the
consumer they just want their their
delivery fee or their hourly wage and
they just want to get their route done
so there's there's a disconnect there so
what we do is we connect
the merchant and the consumer
at that moment of delivery which is a
very powerful moment you can capture
their eyes and their thoughts what do
you think about this product um
would you like to buy more what else do
you want to buy advertisements that sort
of thing there's lots that we can do
when we reconnect them at that moment
i like that you i think that's what most
entrepreneurs do right they decide to
create the idea comes from the fact that
they had a problem and they are trying
to solve it um and so i think i think
that's so fascinating it just no matter
what industry that's always the case so
talk to me about some of the biggest
challenges you had um building in crypto
um
well
i think regulatory uncertainty is is the
biggest cloud that hangs over us like
how do we how do we go about these
different things in a way that's not
going to wrap a noose around us in the
future or bring bring trouble and so we
did a lot of due diligence we have a
legal team that is heavily in in the
space
and uh they're working on some good
things for us but
that that was you know it's more of a
concern that didn't necessarily make it
difficult it made it a little bit more
tedious because we have to examine every
different
aspect
um
i guess difficulty is the ux really
because the user experience in crypto
you know it's not good we got to find
that and that's something that we're
working on trying to do we really want
to um make it easy for people to get
crypto right ultimately bitcoin i think
that that will become the global reserve
of store value it's going to replace
gold why not it's better 10 times better
in every every way um so if i believe
that to be the case
there's a transfer of wealth coming and
i want to i want to empower the people
effectively so our our app is a tool
it's like if bitcoin is the uh the gold
rush
then our app is picks and shovels and we
want to empower people to go out and
mine it for themselves rather than being
mined for your data and your value by
big tech go out and mine this this new
coming um store value for yourself
how did you how did you get into crypto
i don't know what get into crypto
oh one of my uh one of my drivers
he started working for me and he told me
i remember an unnamed token i don't want
to name it
yeah he told me how you turn which token
was that
tron that was tron yeah yeah he said i
turned 1500 into 40k and i was like
really tell me more um but that that
spun me down the rabbit hole of
um the tech i i because i knew about the
profit making you know i was a little
bit concerned there was a lot of fun at
that time in 2017 and so i was kind of
hands off
uh
but i did my due diligence find out that
wasn't the token i wanted um there were
other tokens i wanted ultimately bitcoin
is what you want and i want to put it in
the hands of other people so you know
why not arm them with the ability to do
so monetize your feedback your data your
input your thoughts how do you feel
about the products you buy and the
places that you buy them from and that's
very powerful tools for the merchants
and the brands because they can look at
that aggregate and and just make their
stuff better
yeah and i think sometimes like when you
do building crypto and you know you
build whatever it is you're building
whether it's just like your own brand
whether it's uh whether you know whether
it's you're investing in your trading
you do get a lot of backlash um so i'm
just wondering have you had any backlash
from i don't know when you try i don't
know any any backlash from whether it's
like colleagues family friends
what kind of issues have you faced
and i i don't think we had a lot of
backlash um
we were i mean it's been a blessing you
know we had a great reception from a
particular community we built our back
end processes our smart contracts on the
zilliqa platform which is the first
public network to have sharding which
makes transactions pretty fast and
scalable and cheap there are other
cheaper options out there right now but
you know they have centralization issues
and every network has its own problems
um we don't want to be tribalistic so
our back end exists there but we want to
uh deploy uh the ability for users to
earn
credits and rewards and tokens on their
own favorite network we don't want to
have tribes fighting and we only be
isolated to one chain if you love
bitcoin and you want to just scan for
stats we want to make that happen if you
want to convert into solana or avax or
ether any number of tokens phantom if
you want to have those tokens because
every token or every um i guess smart
contract layer one protocol
has its own community and rather than
alienate any one community we want to
make it feasible for everybody to uh you
know enjoy
the ability to monetize their feedback
that's interesting so how how is that
possible so you're the backend is
entirely on zilliqa is that right
right
so what happens is is you know when you
confirm and deliver you you you go
through the process of the app uh you
get credits and you can then claim them
as we have a kyc process um to make sure
that we we stay in bounds and and um
that's working
very good for us yeah got to be
compliant um but that will authorize
your wallet and then you're able to
claim
a token
that you can then convert into other
tokens um and and so we have on the
pipeline right now
making that much easier
and wrapping up the gap because right
now the
challenge there is gas
getting silica is hard particularly here
in america um and we don't want new uses
why is it hard in america
it's just not it's not all coinbase um
we don't have access to finance uh we
have like
there's only a few exchanges and getting
crypto is hard period full stop right uh
you got to go through this huge kyc
process
and um that's troublesome man you've
been in it for a while you you're an
evangelist you're doing a great job of
being ambassador for for crypto and
bitcoin in particular and we want to do
the same thing but it's hard because
trying to get people to understand how
to create a wallet and secure the
private key and not and secure the
private key again you know be very safe
there um and then operate and trade and
swap and do all these things it's very
complicated for for people that are not
native to this system and we want to
make that easy because we believe we can
be an onboarding platform for people in
the crypto rather than having to figure
all that out and go and buy it
just tell us how you felt about your
purchase and you can earn it
so when they oh i see so when they are
involved they
there is it's like using a cus it's like
using a custodian right like there is no
private key there is no there is no seed
phrase there is no like
serious responsibility or self-classy
that needs to be taken is that correct
no currently we are non-custodial so we
we want users to oh
non-custodial yeah we don't want to
control that we want users to be able to
if you earn a reward we want you to own
it you know and do what you want trade
it swap it hold it stake it we have all
of those options for you um right now
you can turn it into sats satoshi's but
there's you know like five different
steps and three different exchanges you
have to do that on and so we need to fix
that that's our that's our goal for h1
we'll be at the blockchain or the
bitcoin conference in miami and and
maybe we'll have some progress there
that we can share
but yeah ultimately ultimately
we want to make it much easier
because currently to claim or convert or
do any of that you've got to have gas
and on ethereum nobody is going to be
able to claim any tokens at those gas
prices silica enables us to do so for
much cheaper it's a few pennies but
still you know at scale that's not good
we cannot just front the gas so we've
got some different
contract standards that we're looking to
deploy in the coming weeks and months to
to make the user experience just much
better
so that a new user can earn crypto claim
it and then do whatever they want
immediately
speaking of ethereum i tried to sell on
nfc yesterday and it was going to cost
me 200 i was like
i'm gonna wait for a higher offer like
that was crazy
it's so insane i know um but you make a
really important point in that like
these taking self-custody is so
complicated for people that don't
understand seed phrase private keys like
understanding you know
good self custody practices
what is it like the concept of a wallet
you know is even complicated so how how
do you how do you on board people then
because like obviously the idea is great
um you get rewarded for leaving a review
which i think is just amazing um i wish
we could i wish we got rewarded on uber
for leaving a review the amount of ubers
i take um i literally never
put in say that again who said patent
pending um
yeah no it's true it's true i never
leave a review i actually never leave
reviews because why you're not devised
to do so yeah you're not benefited in
any way shape or form and it just takes
time away from you
yes
exactly so like i love the idea i'm just
thinking you know
how is the average person going to
understand this and on board them their
self themselves and and that's that's at
the height of our our discussions and
our our strategy overall our number one
goal this year is is to expand and get
more users because ultimately it makes
the the economy the ecosystem more more
resilient and more valuable and and
strengthens and hardens the the value
proposition that we bring to merchants
and it's you know it's synergistic but
it's difficult
so um
currently our focus is people who are
crypto natives they understand how to do
some of the the bare essentials and then
we plan to we're going to open a seed
round here probably this quarter um and
then try to scale up the team to be able
to deploy to multiple multiple layer
ones and then as well as just improve
the overall user experience because we
want it to be
super simple for somebody to to come in
and also we have educational materials
within the app and we're going to build
that out you so you can come to the app
similar to like a coin base and things
like that because we do where the
responsibility of if if we can succeed
on our goals then we have the propensity
to become a very
powerful onboarding platform for
non-crypto natives to get into the space
and that's a responsibility that we're
not going to take lightly we want to
educate them and equip them to navigate
safely um and not step on any landmines
you know we want to shepherd them in
that way
i have a question just like about um
motivation because i've been um
reading a lot online um about people
struggling to remain motivated when
they're building businesses right
um so where does your where does your
passion and your motivation come to
build
that's a good question i'm i'm super
competitive that's my little brother
he is a retired army vet retired
firefighter anesthesiologist with his
own practice real estate agent great guy
and you know we we compete against each
other for for that but also
my father uh he was in a wheelchair he
had an illness when i was 12 he went to
the hospital and was gone five months we
left our house moved in with my grandma
and it was it was quite the experience
right but he was an entrepreneur he
before that before his accident he had
us out there delivering newspapers and
yellow pages people don't remember that
it was like google it was a four inch
google on paper yellow pages at like age
of nine in in ten um and so i've always
had that drive to want to
not work for somebody else and not be
tired not be trading my time
for a set wage but exerting my energy
and getting recumbents for that like you
know
in in uh in parallel with my efforts
and so it's it can be hard sometimes as
an entrepreneur especially when you you
hit slaughters values and peaks and you
just gotta
go back to your uh
your original motivations your original
inspiration why did you want to build
this in the first place and if that was
vain and there was nothing there if it
was superfluous then you're not going to
have anything to fall back on and you
you might not be able to continue but if
you had a solid foundation for wanting
to start something
then then you can succeed and in my case
you know my pops was in a wheelchair
running an insurance company from the
bedroom and doing taxes and this kind of
stuff still getting it not stopped by
the loss of his legs and so i want to i
want to honor that legacy and go out and
you know start something and make it
great
it's always good to have a good example
um but it's funny because it's funny
because like a lot of people um talk
about how the nine to five is the safest
option right and i was watching a video
yesterday actually um
it was jim carrey speaking saying that
his father wanted to be a comedian
um and he said that he he said but it
was too risky so he went and got a nine
to five
when jim carrey was then 12 years old
his father lost his safe job
and so like
he would have been safer going ahead and
you know building something and chasing
his dreams so yeah it's very scary i
mean you have to take a lot of risk you
effectively i mean it's it's akin to
taking your own sovereignty over
finances right when you become your own
custodian of your your wealth
yeah then that's a big responsibility
it's on your shoulders and it's similar
with with uh entrepreneurship you've got
to
take risk it might cost you some money
it's going to cost you some time that's
for sure mental capacity vacations all
kind of stuff that you might want to do
you can't because you need to accomplish
these goals if you want to succeed um
but
yeah overall
i mean it's a fun game do you think that
nine to five is is really that safe or
do you feel safer no i don't i mean my
my previous nine to five before i before
i uh like i had a
i was managing warehouse um
furniture warehouse and i was i was good
i was good at my job i was efficient my
reward for getting done sooner than
everybody and and doing a better job
than everybody was grunt work now i just
gotta you gotta you gotta wait you got
two hours left on your shift so go sweep
the floors no my value is worth more
than that i you know i'm outperforming
everybody and there was no incentive for
me to perform better and so
i i can see the flipped model of that
with my delivery company because i don't
pay my drivers hourly they all earn
piece work effectively every delivery
that they do they earn two dollars or
more
um and some of them are doing
250 stops a day um on some days so
they're making good money um but they're
incentivized to do so when i got into it
the the more you take the more you make
and the sooner you do it the sooner you
go home so there's incentive there and
that's that changes everything and
there's no there's not much incentive
with nine to fives unless it's climbing
that corporate ladder um
for the purpose of you know just being
elevated or for the purpose of gleaning
knowledge and learning what you can from
those different roles and then applying
it to something in the future there's
value there but yeah
i mean you make you make an you make an
interesting point and that you know you
worked super efficiently better than
everyone else so then your last like
three hours of the day you had to do
grunt work and you're just like i could
be spending my time more efficiently it
just it doesn't really make sense
there's no it's just a continuous cycle
and then i often find and i hope no one
like gets offended by this but i also
find like when when that's the case and
you know you're not building for you
you're building for somebody else and
there's no direct incentive
i often find like the work done is never
as good as it would be if you had an
incentive to do it for yourself or even
if you had an incentive to make more
money right like but just because you
finished your work faster doesn't mean
you're going to make more money
absolutely it comes down to ownership i
mean as an owner you you put risk and
skin into the game and so if you don't
perform well you you might lose a
contract and that sort of thing you're
going to lose out um
it's different with the 9 to 5 when
you're working for somebody else and
they're just paying you hourly
that's just not there
yeah it's true it's it's uh it's an
interesting interesting way of doing it
um
i
i did some work with them some people
that worked at their nine to fives and
they they hated their job and there was
no incentive to provide good quality
service
um so it kind of just ties back to the
whole idea with package portal and that
you know you are directly incentivized
um because you want to you know you
every there's an incentive in every way
yeah incentive is everything and and you
know there's a lot of value i don't want
to disparage nine to fives because i
learned a lot in the ones that i worked
they were hard a lot of them were not
rewarding at all financially but um you
know the lessons that i learned and the
work ethic that it that it forced and
ingrained within me was valuable
but ultimately it's it's i don't like to
use dead end but it's a it's a
cul-de-sac because
you cannot take ownership you can't
control your destiny you are effectively
um you know you're joining somebody
else's mission and that's cool for a
time but me you know being the com
competitor that i am and wanting to
achieve and
and control my own destiny and my
schedule um and get maximum value out of
my efforts and my energies because i
think that they can provide value then i
want to pursue that and and you can't do
that working for somebody else you just
have to do it yourself
yeah for sure like i don't want to
discredit that either um i just for me i
just think it's dangerous i just think
it's dangerous um especially with
inflation right like the uk today is
just hit its highest um level of
inflation um in 30 years i think it's
that five i know it's at 5.4 percent and
that's just a shy number if you don't
include the um the cpi and so you know
you can't turn around and up your prices
according to inflation whereas you can
when you're an entrepreneur
mm-hmm
yeah you have total flexibility you can
do it when you can set the prices change
the prices if there's customers that you
just want to give a smoking deal to you
can do that you control it um and that
gives you a lot of power in sales and
communication and networking and really
it's just about taking on that risk so
that you can absorb power
um and it's a lot of work you know it
not to shy away from from the long
nights and weekends and the energy
mental taxation i was not just great i'm
only i just turned 22. i'm just kidding
five years no i just turned 40. um and
my hair's black on top but it's you know
it's right here and some of that stress
is from entrepreneurship having
within the logistics space as well every
package needs to be delivered every day
it doesn't matter if this guy breaks
down or his he's having a baby or she's
sick none of that matters i still got to
get these packages out um
so
again ownership
even when it gets hard you got to figure
out a way to get it done that's my motto
let's figure it out when there's a
problem or a challenge let's figure it
out
it's true um and how do you stay then
like ahead of the game and stay
innovating and stay creating because
like for me personally i do like that's
the challenge that i find um you always
want to be
trendy
you know as trendy as possible you want
to be at the forefront of innovation you
want to be really like yeah trendy is
the word so how do you keep creating and
innovating
that's a good question it kind of
links back to the motivation i think
that if you're solving a problem for
people
then you're going to stay relevant
you're going to stay trending and stay
in the moment because people want what
you have or what you provide and
ultimately what we provide is is a
marketplace for them to monetize their
data and monetize their feedback which
is huge and then so so that's benefit
for them big value ad but then
conversely the merchant um if they're
paying six dollars for a signature fee
right now they can get it for like a
nickel you know much less than 97
savings or something to that effect but
also they can engage with their
consumers in a whole new new way so it's
major value for the merchant major value
for the consumer um it's it's
synergistic and and beneficial for both
parties and we that gives us confidence
we can stand behind that we're saying
we're not here to siphon value away from
one party um whether it be to line our
own pockets or um just to
help somebody succeed at the expense of
another we don't want that we want to
decentralize power effectively
carriers right now like we said at the
top of the car carriers have all power
they control the data and they're biased
it's all in a silo they're biased if
there's a problem they can obfuscate or
hide that from you right if there's no
problem if everything goes good one time
they'll amplify that i have no insight
even my delivery company i provide data
and i have to pay my broker to access
that data and no consumer i've ever
delivered to in all of my time has been
able to look at that data and we need to
change that the merchants should be able
to own their data and the consumer
should generate it
sounds very web too sounds like the
mainstream media and everything that's
going on
hiding hiding information amplifying
break it down i mean it should be
transparent um public you know we want
we want merchants and consumers to join
you know to band together effectively to
hold carriers accountable to better
service and honest data
yeah
there's not a lot of that sometimes
so what advice would you give people who
are looking to um you know start
building something for themselves in
crypto um you know whether it's um
whether it's
working in the industry full-time or
whether it's actually building some form
of product like you've built
all right those are probably two
different approaches i think working on
something full-time find something that
you're passionate about and find a team
that you can work well with and that
you're really ultimately a vision or a
product that you're excited about
because when your passion is there it's
easy to work i love i love what we built
i think it's solving a lot of problems
it's huge i want to tell everybody do
you see how cool this is you know i want
to be calm but but i'm very passionate
about it because i know that it's it's
providing value um and so if you can
align yourself with the team or a vision
or a product that is that fits you in
that manner um for you i think it's
bitcoin you you've latched yourself to
like the coming revolution of of this
financial uh traditional financial
market being upended right and you're an
evangelist for that so it's easy you
enjoy this i'm sure yeah i'm a freedom
maximalist
my sister lives in panama she sailed
down from maryland she's been there for
about two years now
oh wow where abouts in panama
i forget the name of the city okay i've
never been there but i just remembered
that um yeah
yeah yeah yeah freedom it's all about
freedom
yeah freedom maximalist like i totally
agree with you i think when you do
something which you truly love and you
feel that there's purpose in it then you
have to do it i hate the idea that you
have to monetize your hobbies right
people often say do something that
you're good at and a lot of people say
no just you don't have to monetize
everything just be happy and enjoy it
right but at the same time like you
should be what's the point in working if
it doesn't if there's no end if it
doesn't if it doesn't inspire you to
wake up every day like you don't want to
be living for the weekends you want to
be you know you want to wake up on a
monday and be like wow today i'm going
to change the world and like you know
whether you're
whether you're directly changing the
world or whether you're you know just
doing something on a small scale i think
it's so fulfilling you know and even
just like everything that's going on in
the world right now with lockdowns and
things like that like it it for me
personally it just ties into crypto like
it just does and so it'll for me it will
just makes sense you know i agree and
there's never been a a better time in
the history of man than to try to seize
on some of your dreams and your goals
and to take that leap and and add a
little bit of risk because
i mean i think the internet is powerful
you can you can learn anything that you
want to you don't need a college degree
that costs a hundred thousand dollars
you can just go do your research and
figure it out because you know college
degree does not give you applied
knowledge it gives you just learn
apply it
sorry no but you know it speaks to the
to the uh the desires and the goals and
if you can find something that you're
passionate about um then it's easy you
hear it all the time i've heard it since
i was a little kid oh i love what i do
so
it's recent i'm not working yeah yeah
i'm not working because i love it you're
still working that's that's bs
when i'm i'm dog tired i gotta fire off
an email this i got deadlines this and
that
um and you can't drop the ball there's
calls that you don't want to take you
might not feel good you might have
things going on my dogs are going nuts
they're driving me crazy today you know
my wife whatever the case may be you
want to you want to be able to take care
of your family and and do good work but
sometimes it becomes difficult however
if you love what you're doing you're
passionate about what it is like the end
goal is the north star
of the company that you work for or the
company that you start
then it becomes easy
yeah i mean it it is an interesting
point there's no one else that's going
to do it other than you like for example
imagine if i was so sick today there's
no one else that's going to do this show
that maybe i am sick you wouldn't know i
have to just have to turn up just have
to shut up
yeah yeah exactly you got to get it done
yeah you know delivery every package
every day you got to get it done if the
car breaks down or or this happens we
still got to do it
exactly you got to find a solution so
what's the future then of um package
portal what can we expect i know you
said some educational content could be
coming um i know you said that you want
to make earning satoshi's easier the
user experience but what else can we
expect
all right so much yeah i've got we've
got a road map on our on our twitter
profile you can check us out
packageportal.com you can see that there
also um we've got a lot this year we've
got nfts coming and they will be
utility-based yeah not just cool art
we'll have that but they're going to
have function to where
you know if you own one of our entities
you don't just earn one reward you earn
three or five there'll be multiple
multipliers triple satoshis yeah you can
earn five satoshi's first scan and and a
lot of cool stuff that we can integrate
with with the non-functional tokens
also direct support for multiple layer
ones and and satoshi's bitcoin itself
um
we've got our legal team in wyoming i
think i mentioned them earlier they've
been working on some stuff we had a call
with the secretary of state there
because we're incorporated in 2019
before web 3 was cool we've been here
guys
we've been working with the secretary of
state on some different applications and
they're really excited about the utility
of our token um like you know the most
definitive textbook case
i don't want to speak for them but um
that's the vibe that we get that they
just they really could use us as an
example for um what a utility token
should look like how to operate and
navigate going back to bootstrapping we
never did any otc sales we never did any
icos or raises or anything like that any
token that we ever swapped was through a
dex um in conservative amounts over time
never when a price was dropping to to
preserve the economy because you want to
build a community and our community
loves and trust us they rode with us for
a long time and we love that and
that's powerful for us because the
network effect is huge word of mouth is
incredible
yeah no absolutely is so
before we say goodbye where can well
actually first do you have any like last
final words that you want to share with
everyone
ah
go download the app
um
send us a message if you need some help
you know we're excited to build i think
that uh we might become a little bit
more
publicized in the coming weeks and
months as we try to to hit our goals and
the objectives that we have just to make
it very easy for people to earn crypto
and then swap and trade and and do
whatever they want in d5 for delivery
data web3 for e-commerce we built it
we're here and it's launched in this
live and now we just want to tell the
world about it so
you might be able to go yeah we are
early so where can people um find you um
what's the twitter tell us everything
everything is package portal one word um
spelled normally so twitter
medium our website
uh anything it's all we got the rights
early so it's package supporter you can
look us up that way find us in the app
store the google play store you can
download it start earning today
um
yeah
and guys don't forget follow jg on
twitter for um just to stay up to date
and
from the jagged one yeah the giant one
there you go um i want to thank you so
much it's been so nice chatting with you
um i love to have a good conversation
about you know building entrepreneurship
um removing middlemen becoming more
sovereign over everything that you do um
so i want to thank you so much it's been
so great having you on
100 yeah i love talking about this stuff
too it's easy you know sovereignty over
your finances over your time over your
vision and goals ultimately your life um
and then if you align that with doing
something that adds value to the world
then then what's to stop you
i totally agree with you that's the
perfect package so guys don't forget
follow jg follow package portal and
don't forget to tune in next week we'll
see you then
[Music]